good afternoon i'm captain nick farisi
of the spring valley area command
i am joined today by members of the
asian community
as we stand in solidarity uh to talk
about recent events and what we're doing
here locally to keep our community safe
thank you all for coming today so that
we can discuss this community
partnership
between the lvmpd and our asian
community and ensuring that we all feel
safe
in our community in light of the many
recent events that have occurred
throughout the country targeting asian
americans
topped with a horrific shooting in
georgia that targeted massage parlors
where innocent people lost their lives
there is a legitimate safety concern
for our asian community here in las
vegas even though we have not had any
documented crimes
against this community related to recent
events
we understand as a people the fear that
is being discussed today
is real it's based on attacks occurring
across the country
and as a police agency we want to make
sure everyone feels safe
and protected lvmpd
has always maintained a strong
partnership with key community
stakeholders within the asian community
such as the asian chamber of commerce
the asian american group
and several other business owners such
as bamboo bridges
it has been important for us to keep
lines of communication open
and address concerns specific to this
community
spring valley area command is entrusted
with patrolling
the spring mountain corridor which is
famously known as chinatown
we always strive to maintain strong
presence in this vital community
with patrols community outreach and
education
upon learning of the events in georgia
we immediately
increased our patrols in the area and
provided
outreach to business owners and patrons
ensuring that they are safe and letting
them know that they do not need to live
in fear
we continue to communicate directly with
established stakeholders to share
information
which in turn they shared within their
communities
while this fear is understandable it is
important to stress that lvmpd
is committed to the safety of our
community and we will not allow
a specific group to be targeted or
attacked
i believe through communication
community engagement
and building trust that we can keep
chinatown
and our asian community safe you will
see
increased patrols but the important work
is done
out of view with people that are here
with me today
these are leaders that we work closely
with every single day
it is important that we all understand
and hear each other
in order to remove barriers and ensure
the well-being and the safety for us all
i ask for the community's support in
reporting
any and all suspicious activity being a
good witness
and looking out for your neighbor are
paramount to the success of las vegas
our asian community plays a crucial role
in our city
and they need and they deserve the
support of all of us
to move past hate and ignorance and to
live
safe and free in this place that we all
call home
i'll now have a couple of the members
representing these groups come up and
say a few words
uh the first will be sunny veswana with
the asian american
or the asian chamber of commerce
let me just take this off it's all right
good afternoon everyone uh on behalf of
the las vegas asian chamber of commerce
we would like to extend our condolences
to the friends and families of the
victims of the shooting in georgia
i want to thank everyone here today um
there's a lot of people up here
i want to make sure i don't miss anybody
let's start with uh
jerry jerry schroeder's here from
commissioners i'm sorry confirmed
woman susie lee's office jerry's here
commissioner jones is here commissioner
we have higher higher ed represented in
the house hello
here bamboo bridges of course apollo
nafa ac dc
aapi commissioners here and of course
my chamber is here as well represented
so but thank you
especially to captain ferraci and las
vegas metro for your continued support
of the aapi community the community
outreach
program that metro has is the best i've
ever seen
and it is truly built on trust and
transparency
first and foremost hate crimes against
any race
should never be tolerated we are very
fortunate as reports show
that we have not had an incident here in
las vegas
i do urge everyone to stay safe
and be diligent but more so this should
be a time
for the aapi community to unite and
watch out for one another
the asian chambers founded information
shows that aapi
are the fastest growing minority
population here in nevada
we are great contributors to our
community at least half of the medical
personnel
fighting the pandemic are aapi we have
over 21 000 small businesses
in nevada over 300 just here in the
spring corridor alone
it is nice to see all of us here today
united so that our voice is heard
but now it is time for us to build
cultural unity
a community that protects each other
respects one another
faces hard times like these together and
uplifts
the members of our community just always
remember where there is unity
there's always victory thank you very
much
now let me introduce dr rosita lee
thank you thank you good good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen it's
it's great that everybody's here and
it's beautiful weather
and i want to say this we are strong the
aapi community is strong
all you see is just a little bit the t
one tenth
but we are in the thousands here we are
more than two hundred fifty thousand and
when we hear something that happens to
one of us
it affects us but when we hear something
that makes us afraid we don't like that
and you know all the crimes that have
been happening to our asians more than 3
000 that we can count
not here in nevada thank you lord but
throughout the country
and we must prevent it we must prevent
it from happening here
in las vegas in nevada i'm so glad that
we have
um our commissioner justin jones who's
here to to listen to us
and also um i'm happy to to see that
former uh our former congressman reuben
kuhlman from the hispanic community
is here to support our work that we do
there are so many that i could name but
let me tell you this
we have gloria kowili for instance from
the asian american
pacific labor and she is so
active as as young as we are we still
we still run around trying to help our
community members
and you know that's what we're all about
do you know why i've been doing this for
more than 40 years
here in nevada because i have children
i have grandchildren and now i have
20 great grandchildren
and i am working to make sure that our
country
stays safe and we thank lvmpd thank you
to our
our captain here who is always so firm
with us
but he's also loving at the same time
thank you so much
and you know without you the media how
can we be heard
we have voices our amy has a voice
in fact she wrote a book um all of you
know and of course we have a voice here
with helen who writes about us but we
need
you we need you the the
reporters those who have newspapers
those who have magazines those who have
blogs
we need you to talk about us we have
been sort of silent not that silent
but you're going to hear from all of us
loud and clear
even johnny jackson likes to shout it
out
and it's good it's good that we speak up
but it's even better if you report about
it
because we need to have others know that
the asian-american pacific islander
community
is alive and well is contributing to the
economy
we're the ones that help like in this
case
remember when james chen first started
this and i worked with him
and it is now a beautiful complex james
is retired
relaxed and he's enjoying life so what
am i doing
why am i not retired
and so right now we're gonna and we're
gonna wrap it up right now
mindy's tapping me on my back but i
wanna let you know
that senator cortez masto called me this
morning
she's very concerned about what we are
doing here
and we're going to be meeting with her
at a round table we will discuss
and we will look for solutions and
that's what we're going to do and that's
why we're here
to discuss solutions thank you very much
thank you very much uh thank you
everybody for attending thank you for
our community partners
uh to sum it all up i i think uh
it says it of itself we can't do this
alone i think it's lost on a lot of
people that
this is our community too we live here
as police officers
our key community stakeholders live here
our families live here we're raising
kids here
so we all have a vested interest in this
and it's only through a complete
community partnership
through the media through the viewers
through our key community stakeholders
and our residents to come to the table
and be part of solutions and make this
community safer so with that i could
take a few questions
and then after that we'll stick around
for some more questions
yeah so we always have that's a good
question thank you the question was
asking you know what type of extra
patrol we're having in the area
and essentially we always have a strong
footprint in chinatown
uh just a spring valley area command
this is this is the heart of our
community
and the heart of our area command but
with the recent attacks just like with
other things that you've seen when we
have a
homegrown terrorism or international
terrorism as an agency
we always step up our footprint to key
critical infrastructure
so right now that key critical
infrastructure is hit in our chinatown
where the predominant asian businesses
are located
so you'll see both over and hopefully
you won't see the covert
mechanisms that are here but you know
our biggest concern while we don't
believe that there's any targeted
threats here towards asians
uh we're always worried about copycats
so increasing our footprint
for the next couple of days and weeks to
come we'll just
reassure the safety of everybody
no uh we're we're a proactive police
agency
and uh as the bureau commander here my
job is to be accountable to the
community and a big portion of my
community
is the asian community so i talk to
these people on a weekly basis
not just when times are bad but in times
are good because it really is a
collaborative effort it's a partnership
yeah i mean it's definitely something
that i can't hide from i mean that is a
challenge with any police agency when
we're dealing with other cultures that
aren't originally from here
there's definitely barriers but again
that's why we rely on partnerships such
as these behind us
to help remove those barriers and i'll
say to all the audience that's listening
you know
we need to know if there's a problem and
i don't know about it how can i fix it
so if people don't want to come forward
and report crimes then we don't know
that there's a problem and
regardless of what your status is in
this country or what your beliefs are
the police department doesn't take that
into account every victim is treated
with the same empathy dignity and
respect that
they deserve and we will investigate
every crime to the fullest
thank you very much we'll take some
further questions later after the fact
off to the side
thank you for being here